hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live in der Ukraine ist es seit 15
Monaten grausamer Alltag auch in den
letzten 24 Stunden gab es wieder Drohnen
und Raketenangriffe besonders die
Hauptstadt Kiew wurde zum Ziel
mindestens ein Mensch wurde dabei
getötet aber auch in Moskau melden Sie
heute morgen Drohnenangriffe auf die
Hauptstadt
verantwortlich dafür machte das
russische Verteidigungsministerium die
Ukraine die ukrainische Regierung die
wies die Vorwürfe zurück die Bilder die
wir hier sehen am Ende aus Moskau am
Anfang eben aus Kiew das sind die
Meldungen heute des Tages der
ukrainische Präsidenten Berater podoljak
sagte natürlich sind wir nicht direkt
daran beteiligt stimmt das oder nicht
könnte das eine neue Strategie der
Vergeltung sein dass alles soll heute
bei uns Thema sein mehr Details
Hintergründe und auch eine Analyse in
dieser Sendung mit militärexpertin
Birgit Franke darum soll es gehen stellt
gerne fragen schreibt Kommentare live in
den Stream oder eben auch per Mail das
ist bei uns auch möglich wir können
jetzt am Anfang dieser Sendung zuerst
mit unserer Korrespondentin in Moskau
sprechen mit für begabt und auch mit
unserem Reporter mit Tim Kröger in Kiew
hallo schön dass ihr da seid
komme ich zuerst zu dir was für Ziele
wurden genau in Moskau getroffen kannst
du uns mehr über die Einzelheiten wir
haben eben schon kurz Bilder von leicht
beschädigten Gebäuden gesehen kannst du
uns mehr zu diesen Zielen sagen
ja die Drohnen die sind heute in den
frühen Morgenstunden alle samt westlich
und südwestlich der Moskauer Innenstadt
eingeschlagen ob sie abgeschossen wurden
oder abgestürzt sind das lässt sich
nicht in jedem Fall ganz genau sagen
aber brisant ist dass eben viele von
diesen Drohnen in Wohngebieten in
niedergegangen sind die bekannt dafür
sind dass dort die russische Elite wohnt
also Wirtschaftsgrößen politische Größen
und dann hat der Ministerpräsident mich
Schuss den dort einen Anwesen und eben
auch Präsident Putin hat eine Residenz
nur wenige Kilometer von dem Ort an dem
eine dieser Drohnen eingeschlagen haben
soll
und Tim in der Ukraine seit 24 Stunden
also wieder Angriffe im ganzen Land
wohnen und Raketenangriffe kannst du uns
was über das Ausmaß erzählen und auch ob
die Luftabwehr der ukrainischen Seite
eigentlich reicht für dieses Ausmaß an
Drohnen und Raketen Angriffen
genau also wir haben jetzt hier in den
letzten 24 Stunden massive Angriffe
gehabt heute tagsüber war es etwas
ruhiger aber wie gesagt bis in die
frühen Morgenstunden ist vor allem die
Hauptstadt Kiel mit Raketen und mit
Drohnen angegriffen worden das ganze hat
ja schon begonnen am in der Sonntagnacht
und ging dann auch gestern am Montag
weiter was ungewöhnlich ist das ist
sozusagen tagsüber solche Raketen und
Drohnenangriffe gab das war schon massiv
die Menschen leiden darunter hier in der
Ukraine vor allem hier in Kiew vor allem
darunter dass sie eben nachts nicht so
richtig schlafen können und das liegt
daran dass hier nachts über dem ähm am
Himmel über kehrt sozusagen ein ein
Kampf stattfindet zwischen diesen
russischen Raketen und Drohnen und
andererseits der Flugabwehr der Ukraine
also im Moment scheint es so zu sein
dass die Ukraine immer noch in der Lage
sind trotz dieser massiven Welle die
meisten geschosser von Himmel zu holen
sozusagen unschädlich zu machen das was
dann halt passiert ist dass die
Trümmerteile runterfallen und die
richten natürlich schon hier in den
verschiedenen Stadtteilen vom Kiew
Schäden an ob die Flugabwehr das jetzt
noch lange durchhalten kann das ist die
große Frage im Moment ist es so dass die
Ukraine ja in den vergangenen Monaten
zum einen das patriot-system geliefert
bekommen hat also ein sehr modernes
Flugabwehrsystem oder zumindest ein sehr
effektives und dann auch das deutsche
ihres t-system das ist eine deutliche
Verbesserung im Gegensatz dazu wie die
Ukraine am Anfang des Krieges
aufgestellt war also es gibt hier
Soldaten die wir gesprochen haben die in
der Flugabwehr tätig sind die sagen
mittlerweile können wir hier eigentlich
zu 95% sichern aber die Frage ist was
passiert wenn dieser diese Welle die wir
ja im Grunde schon seit Anfang Mai sehen
wenn die weiter in dieser Intensität
anhält wie lange hält dann
beispielsweise die Munition und ich habe
schon den Eindruck dass die russische
Seite hier einmal mehr versucht zum
einen die Bevölkerung zu Vermögen mit
diesem permanenten Angriffen vor allem
nachts aber eben auch wirklich versucht
eine Schwachstelle in der Ukraine
Flugabwehr zu finden oder sie zumindest
so lange zu torieren dass sie irgendwann
nicht mehr gegenhalten kann oder nicht
mehr 100% oder zu einem großen Teil wir
sprechen gleich weiter schauen jetzt
aber erstmal eine Zusammenfassung dieser
Ereignisse von Christina
plötzlich ist der Krieg auch in Moskau
ganz nah am frühen Morgen werden mehrere
Drohnenangriffe gemeldet eine
gewohnhäuser werden leicht beschädigt
die Leute haben geschlafen da war so ein
Summen und dann hat es laut gekracht als
wäre etwas eingeschlagen
der Kreml spricht von einem
terroristischen Angriff beschuldigt die
Ukraine die Regierung dort bestreitet
zumindest direkt beteiligt zu sein
im Gegensatz zu diesen Angriffen vor dem
9 mai handelt es sich jetzt ja um
größere Drohnen die die Reichweite haben
aus der Ukraine auch nach Moskau zu
fliegen das war nichts relativ eindeutig
ukrainische Drohnen
der Drohnen und Einschläge haben in
Moskau Spuren hinterlassen die Wirkung
der Angriffe aber vor allem
psychologisch Kriegslärm und schlaflose
Nächte haben die meisten Moskauer noch
nicht erlebt
in Kiew dagegen kennen sie das nur als
zu gut Nacht für Nacht neue Drohnen
dieses Mal wurde laut Bürgermeister
Klitschko ein Mensch getötet zu den
Angriffen in Moskau sagt er
aber ich Informationen bekommen dass es
eine
Angriffen und Moskau auch nicht
geschlafen und wenn ich mal denke ich
mal hier den Moskau kam ein bisschen
jede Burge von unserer Stadt stehen was
bedeutet das der russische Präsident
meldet sich am Nachmittag Putin lobt die
Flugabwehr sagt aber auch wir werden sie
noch besser machen
wir haben eben gerade kurz am Ende des
Beitrags Putin gesehen gehört was gab es
noch für Reaktionen aus dem Kreml oder
von militärsführer
also bevor sich heute Präsident Putin am
Nachmittag zu Wort gemeldet hat da hat
seinen Kreml Sprecher schon die Ukraine
für das was er einen terroristischen
Angriff nennt verantwortlich gemacht
andere Ministerien gehen auch in diese
Richtung da ist man also ziemlich
einhellig der Meinung die Ukraine hat da
ähm ist für diesen Angriff
verantwortlich das
Verteidigungsministerium hat dann heute
morgen noch bekannt gegeben dass man
eben acht Drohnen unschädlich gemacht
habe das ist insofern interessant als
dass es auch einige Quellen gibt die
durchaus auch Grammel Nase sind die von
viel mehr Drohnen sprechen von viel mehr
unwirkten Flugobjekten die sich heute in
und um Moskau in der Luft befunden haben
sollen da ist die Rede von 25 bis 35
Drohnen es Verteidigungsministerium hat
dann am Nachmittag noch mal nachgelegt
und hat gesagt man werde jetzt
Angriffe auf die sogenannten
entscheidungszentren starten oder
durchführen
damit sind Orte in der Ukraine gemeint
von denen also das russische
Verteidigungsministerium glaubt dass
dort die Verantwortlichen Sitzen für
dieses was hier eben Terror Angriff auf
Moskau genannt wird und Tim wie werden
die Angriffe in Moskau also auf Russland
in der Ukraine bewertet
naja also es gab ja hier vor allem die
Aussage die wir gerade eben schon im
Beitrag gehört haben vom ukrainischen
präsidentenberater podoljak der gesagt
hat er sehe das mit Freude aber die
ukrainische Führung habe damit keine
direkte Verbindung und ich glaube gerade
bei diesem Wort direkt muss man
aufhorchen das ist nämlich keine
ultimative also damit schießt er es
nicht ultimativ aus sondern es gibt dann
womöglich doch eine indirekte Verbindung
und das ist ja die große Frage ist die
Ukraine wirklich für diese Angriffe
verantwortlich im Großen und Ganzen
behält sich die oder hält sich die
ukrainische Führung bei solchen
Angriffen immer bedeckt und wird nie
wirklich offen zugeben dass sie etwas
damit zu tun hat aber natürlich ist der
Zusammenhang beispielsweise auch mit
dieser massiven Angriffswelle von
russischer Seite der zeitliche
Zusammenhang durchaus da das heißt also
es sieht aus wie ein Gegenschlag jetzt
gerade nachdem es in den vergangenen
Tagen ganz besonders schwere Angriffe
hier auf die Ukraine gab und man kann
auch noch mal etwas wieder zurückschauen
da gab es beispielsweise ja auch Anfang
des Monats bereits einen ersten
Drohnenangriff auf Moskau auf den Kreml
direkt da war ja die große Frage ob die
Ukraine dafür verantwortlich ist die
ukrainische Führung hat damals gesagt
nein aber es gab eben doch Berichte das
wo möglich ukrainische Kreise da die
Finger mit im Spiel hatten dann gab es
vor einigen Monaten den Angriff auf die
kart-brücke also die Verbindung zwischen
der Krim und dem russischen Festland
auch damals hat die Ukraine zunächst
gesagt damit haben wir nichts zu tun
jetzt vor einigen Tagen aber hat dann
eben doch ein Geheimdienst der hier
gesagt ja ähm das waren da hatten wir
durchaus unsere Finger mit im Spiel also
man kann es nicht hundertprozentig sagen
aber es passt natürlich schon ins Bild
und es kommt der Ukraine ganz sicherlich
nicht umlegen zum Schluss noch die Frage
an dich füge was macht das mit der
russischen Bevölkerung Drohnenangriffe
in der Hauptstadt
also es ist schon so dass man jetzt von
Russinnen und Russen immer öfter auch
besorgte Worte hört da spielt sicherlich
nicht nur die heutigen Angriffe eine
Rolle sondern eben auch die Tatsache
dass es in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten zu wirklich vielen
Zwischenfällen vor allem in den
grenznahen Regionen gekommen ist zuletzt
auch diese Kampfhandlungen in der Region
Belgorod dann die eben von schon von Tim
erwähnten ähm Drohnen auf den Kreml also
mehr und mehr kommt man sich hier in
Russland auch angegriffen vor und wenn
man sich dann weiter mit den Leuten
unterhält dann wird aber oft deutlich
dass viele wenn nicht da die Mehrheit
der Russinnen und Russen der Erklärung
folgt dass die Tatsache dass ihr Land
jetzt tatsächlich zu einem Zielobjekt
wird dass die für diese Tatsache die
Ukraine und der Westen verantwortlich zu
machen sind danke für die Einschätzung
für veganen Moskau und Tim Krüger in Kia
vielen Dank
und schauen wir uns jetzt mal die Orte
der Angriffe in Moskau an ZDF heute hat
einen Faktencheck durchgeführt diese
Orte verifiziert schauen wir mal rein in
die Bilder sehen also links die Orte
gleich im Bild wo Trümmerteile gefunden
worden sind und sehen gleich dann rechts
im Bild die beschädigten Gebäude die wir
jetzt auch teilweise schon in Bildern
gesehen haben in unseren in unserem
Gespräch eben dass also jetzt hier mal
ein bisschen zu Einordnung wo das ganze
liegt und wir können jetzt auch über die
Orte und noch weitere Details und vor
allem auch eure Fragen sprechen mit
Sicherheitsexperten Ulrike Franke Sie es
uns zugeschaltet vom European Council
und vorhin relations hallo schönen guten
Abend Frau Franke einen schönen Abend
wir haben eben gerade auf der Karte
gesehen wo sich in ja in welchem Gebiet
sich in Moskau das alles ereignet haben
soll wir haben auch schon von für begane
Einschätzung dazu gehört können Sie sich
einen Reim daraus machen jetzt auch mit
diesen Orten wo die Trümmerteile
gefunden hat wo es Einschläge gegeben
haben soll was das Ganze auf sich gehabt
haben soll
ich meine ehrlich gesagt muss man zu
diesem Zeitpunkt halt sagen dass wir
sehr sehr wenig wissen die Informationen
die wir kriegen können schlecht
überprüft werden kommen letztendlich aus
dem Internet und Co daher ja wissen wir
noch relativ wenig aber wenn ich mir die
Orte angucke ich sehe jetzt nicht die
direkten logischen Ziele hier ähm kann
natürlich sein aber mir erscheint es
fast eher das ist einfach grundsätzlich
darum gehen Moskau zu treffen und ob sie
dieses Haus oder das andere Haus ist im
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob du die große
Rolle spielt ich denke das ist jetzt
Spekulation aber ich denke diese
Angriffe waren letztendlich dafür da als
Signalwirkung um den Krieg eben zum
gewissen gerade auch nach Moskau nach
Russland hinein zu tragen und der
Bevölkerung in Russland eben auch zu
zeigen und zu signalisieren ja also ihr
seid im Krieg dieser Krieg findet nicht
nur irgendwie weit weg und in der
Ukraine statt die alles entscheidende
Frage natürlich wer war es vielleicht
reden wir da mal ein bisschen über die
Fakten was wir zumindest gesichert sagen
können also was waren das für Drohnen
und wie weit können die Fliegen von wo
aus könnten die gesteuert worden sein
wenn Sie uns damit ein bisschen Details
versorgen könnten absolut ja also
wir haben jetzt ja Informationen in der
Form von Videos und von Bildern von von
den Angriff von den Abschüssen und von
Brack teilen wenn ich mir diese Videos
und Bilder ansehen denke ich zwei
verschiedene Modelle identifizieren zu
können das wären beides ukrainische
Modelle das ist natürlich nicht
gesichert als dass man so viel nicht
sehen kann und Drohnen letztendlich halt
natürlich doch irgendwie auch alle ein
bisschen ähnlich aussehen vereinfacht
gesagt aber es erscheint mir schon
relativ plausibel dass das vielleicht so
ukrainischen Drohnen sind dieses Thema
an die ich denke sind auch durchaus in
der Lage längere Strecken fliegen die
können auch von der ukrainischen Grenze
geflogen worden sein also moskau ist ja
wie 4500 Kilometer von der ukrainischen
Grenze das ist zumindest plausibel wenn
dem so war und diese wurden tatsächlich
aus der Ukraine kam dann ist das
ziemlich peinlich für die russische
Flugabwehr die ja wohl eben erst über
Moskau eingegriffen hat und wohl auch
einige dieser Drohnen abgeschossen hat
aber wenn die eben hunderte Kilometer
ins Russische Gebiet hinein geflogen
sind unentdeckt unbekämpft ist natürlich
peinlich und das ist das Szenario dass
diese Drohnen Angriffe tatsächlich vom
ukrainischen meditieren und eben aus der
Ukraine geflogen wurden ein anderes
Szenario ist dass die Drohnen aus
Russland gestartet wurden also in mir an
Moskau das wären dann eher hoch
ukraineische Gruppierungen sagen wir mal
die innerhalb von Russland agieren die
müssen dann auch nicht direkt mit dem
ukrainischen Militär in Verbindung
stehen aber können eben zum Beispiel
Drohnen geliefert bekommen haben es
wurde ja schon in ihrem Korrespondent
hat schon erwähnt diese Formulierung wir
haben damit nicht direkt zu tun fand ich
auch sehr interessant also vielleicht
ist es eben das Szenario und das ist
dann natürlich auch einfacher so ein
Angriff zu machen weil eben die Drohne
wie gesagt von weniger weit kommen muss
und und auch weniger Gefahr läuft von
der Flugabwehr erfasst zu werden und als
dritte Szenario ist auch diskutiert wird
ist natürlich einfach ein Angriff unter
falscher Flagge also soll heißen also
ein Angriff den letztendlich ja der
russischen Staat selber durchgeführt hat
bin ich jetzt persönlich hier wenig
plausibel als das ja dieser Angriff
jetzt ja Russland nicht wahnsinnig gut
da stehen lässt also gut sie sagen sie
haben die Drohnen auch abgefangen aber
naja also so richtig gut sieht das ja
nicht aus und Russland braucht ja auch
keine Vorwände mehr ich meine Russland
führt seit 15 Monaten einen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine also da
braucht kein Vorwand für die Eskalation
insofern als ich persönlich diesen
Angriff unter falscher Frage ja wie
wenig wahrscheinlich aber das lässt eben
zu dass es ja entweder das ukrainische
Militär selber oder ukrainische
Gruppierungen in Russland waren
vom von den Drohnen die man sehen kann
wie weit man das einschätzen kann ist
beides auf jeden Fall möglich sie haben
da was angesprochen nämlich eine
Operation unter falscher Flagge dazu gab
es auch eine Frage von Userin oder User
Oberberg er oder sie schrieb bei Youtube
kann es Einfalls Flag gewesen sein um
eine neue Mobilisation zurechtfertigen
es sind 500 km bis zur ukrainischen
Grenze schreibt er oder sie deswegen
noch mal vielleicht die Frage um das um
das klar zu machen könnten solche
Drohnen eben auch aus einer sehr weiten
Entfernung überhaupt gesteuert werden
genau also ich würde sagen es kann
natürlich ein Angriff unter falscher
Flagge sein das kann ich natürlich von
hier aus nicht ausschließen aber es ist
nicht so als könnte man sagen das können
Ukraine ja gar nicht gewesen sein weil
Brunnen nicht so weit liegen kann dem
ist absolut nicht so also es gibt viele
drohnensysteme die hunderte Kilometer
weit fliegen können das ist plausibel ob
das so war wie gesagt kann ich ihn nicht
sagen aber das ist nicht der Grund warum
das Wort Flex sein könnte und dann eben
dieser andere Aspekt ist könnten eben
auch einfach aus Russland also in der
Nähe von Moskau gestartete Drohnen
gewesen sein aber dann eben trotzdem von
ukrainischen
Gruppierungen ob jetzt direkt ans
Militär angeschlossen oder nicht also ja
Vorschlag ist möglich ich halte es für
wenig plausibel aber der Grund warum ich
es ist auf jeden Fall nicht nicht
deswegen nur möglich weil diese Drohnen
anderweitig nicht nicht erklärbar nach
Moskau gekommen sein könnten äh dem den
es nicht sprechen wir vielleicht auch
mal darüber was die Ukraine von solchen
Angriffen hätte es gibt eine Frage von
jemand der sich Spiel kennt Spielkind
nennt will man mit den Angriffen die
russische Luftabwehr von der Ukraine
ablenken fragt der oder die Userin sich
ja das ist eine eine interessante
Theorie also wenn wir jetzt mal davon
ausgehen dass es irgendwie Militär oder
prokrastinische Gruppierungen waren es
kann natürlich einfach erstmal eine
Vergeltung für die ständigen
unaufhörlichen Angriffe auf die
ukrainische Ziele Bevölkerung sein das
ist das erste es kann eine Signalwirkung
sein das hatte ich ja eben angesprochen
auf eben die russische Bevölkerung auch
die russischen Machthaber nämlich ja ihr
seid nicht sicher wir können diesen
Krieg auch nach Russland hinein tragen
das das ist irgendwie nicht nicht
unmöglich oder in der Tat und dass wir
die militärische Logik dass man jetzt
vielleicht auch vermehrt Angriffe auch
Russland und auch Moskau macht damit die
russische Flugabwehr beschäftigt ist
aufgebraucht wird und potentiell auch
wenn das jetzt häufiger der Fall sein
sollte dass die russische Flugabwehr
vielleicht auch ähm Fähigkeiten von der
Frontlinie abziehen muss um dann z.B
Moskau zu schützen weil man eben nicht
ja da Angriffe haben will also das ist
eine militärische Logik die Sinn machen
könnte dafür müsste es aber dann ehrlich
gesagt noch mehr Angriffe geben also das
wird das eine Mal nicht nicht reichen
aber wenn das jetzt quasi das könnte
eine Militär zu sagen wir tragen jetzt
den Krieg auch noch nach nach Russland
hinein um die
Flugabwehr zum gewissen Grad zu binden
aufzubrauchen von der Frontlinie
wegzuziehen das ist ja auch nicht ganz
unähnlich dem was was Russland zum
gewissen gerade macht also Russland
nutzt seine Drohne und Raketen erstmal
zu theorisierung von der
Zivilbevölkerung aber eben auch um die
ukrainische Flugabwehr zu binden und
aufzubrauchen und ja letztendlich eben
auch dann dann dann dann dann zu
verstören und diese diese Logik besteht
allerdings also durchaus auch und wenn
das also vielleicht auch gelesen werden
könnte als ein Akt der Vergeltung sagen
wir mal die Frage von Thomas gralitz was
bringt es der Ukraine so stark in
Russland anzugreifen macht es nicht mehr
Sinn die Kräfte im eigenen Land
einzusetzen also was würden Sie sagen
was wäre wahrscheinlicher ist es wäre es
eher Vergeltung oder wäre es eben
unlogisch weil man weil man
sinnvollerweise also die Kräfte im
eigenen Land einsetzen sollte
ja also bis hier hat ja auch die Ukraine
ganz klar die Kräfte im eigenen
eingesetzt es gab einige vereinzelte
Angriffe innerhalb Russlands allerdings
auch vor allen Dingen militärische Ziele
also zum Beispiel im Dezember hatten wir
ja Angriffe auch mit Drohnen auf
russische Flugfelder das macht sehr viel
Sinn und auch andere Angriffe dieser Art
auch militärische Ziele Munitionsdepots
und anderes das kann ich mir vorstellen
das macht mir die Tiere sind Vergeltung
ganz ehrlich ist ist für mich das
schwächste Argument auch einfach
deswegen weil diese Angriffe haben jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht erreicht was sie
eigentlich wollten sie wurden ja
zumindest zum Großteil wenn ich das
richtig verstehe abgefangen aber selbst
wenn sie alle viele was genau sie auch
immer waren getroffen hätten das ist ja
es steht ja in keinem Verhältnis
irgendwie zu den zu den Hunderten und
Tausenden von Drohnen die die seit
Monaten auf auf dem Ukraine nieder
regnen und und Raketen und so weiter
insofern also Vergeltung ist relativ ähm
einigermaßen unüberzeugen es kann eine
Reaktion sein aber das ist dann hat dann
fast eher symbolischen also man trägt
den Krieg nach Russland hinein um das um
das zu zeigen aber eben vor dem
Hintergrund
tendiere ich momentan noch eher dazu zu
sagen das ist vielleicht
das ist jetzt nicht die erste Priorität
des russischen Militärs die bereiten
ihre Gegend Offensive vor es könnten
vielleicht eher pro ukrainische
Gruppierungen gewesen sein die nur so
halb angeglieder sind ja das ist jetzt
wirklich Spekulation aber ich ich finde
als Vergeltungsmaßnahme auch sowas nur
zum gewissen Grad und man darf ja nicht
vergessen noch ein ein wichtiger Punkt
ich würde mir als als Ukraine es auch
sehr gut überlegen quasi in in Russland
Angriffe zu fliegen auf Zivilbevölkerung
denn natürlich sind Angriffe auch
Russland an sich legitim weil Russland
der ergressor ist seit 15 Monaten keine
Frage es kann Teil der Verteidigung sein
auch Russland anzugreifen aber einen ähm
das Ziel auf die Zivilbevölkerung hilft
ja der ukrainischen Situation nicht
hilft auch ukrainischen Argumentation
und und Standing quasi nicht und würde
Probleme bereiten mit den den westlichen
Unterstützern insofern denke ich
eigentlich dass die Ukraine da eher
vorsichtig ist und ja das alles zusammen
genommen lässt mich jetzt eher denken
dass es wahrscheinlich eher um
Signalwirkung ging vielleicht dieser
Bereich Flugabwehr identifizieren auch
brauchen beschäftigen Vergeltung ist ist
nur so neben Aspekt und vielleicht nicht
das Hauptelement meines erachten sie
haben die westlichen Unterstützer
angesprochen es gibt Reaktion aus den
USA grundsätzlich unterstützen wir keine
Angriffe im Inneren Russlands sagte ein
Sprecher von US Außenminister blinken
und weiter sagte er wir konzentrieren
uns darauf der Ukraine die Ausrüstung
und das Training zur Verfügung zu
stellen die sie braucht um ihr eigenes
souveränes Territorium zurück zu erobern
eine Frage aus dem Stream im weitesten
Sinne dazu von weil der Ware kommt die
Frage er oder sie möchte wissen ist es
für die Ukraine legitim sich auf dem
russischen Boden zu verteidigen also da
geht's natürlich um Fragen wie
Völkerrecht
ja also grundsätzlich die Ukraine wurde
Völkerrechts richtig angegriffen von
Russland und hat jedes Recht sich zu
verteidigen und das kann eben auch
einschließen
Russland selbst anzugreifen jetzt nicht
nach Moskau einzumarschieren aber
militärische Ziele in Russland
anzugreifen ist so wie ich nicht
Juristin nicht völkerrechtlerin das
Hörgerät da verstehe absolut legitim und
kann Teil der Verteidigung sein ähm
anders sieht natürlich aus bei Angriffen
auch die Zivilbevölkerung die wir
Bevölkerung kann leider immer so
genannte Kollateralschäden sein also das
kann auch
egal und legitim sein wenn sie mit
getroffen werden aber als Ziel sind sie
nicht legitim insofern muss man da
vorsichtig sein dass die Ukraine bisher
gemacht hat soweit wir das eben wissen
Angriffe auch ja klarere militärische
Ziele wie Flugplätze und anderes das ist
sicherlich
legitim und und auch vom Völkerrecht
gedeckt die westlichen Unterstützer das
haben sie ja angesprochen
haben aber Sorge dass irgendwie geartete
Angriffe innerhalb des russischen
Territoriums eine weitere Eskalation des
Krieges wäre und und versuchen das ja
versuchen letztendlich die Ukraine davon
abzuhalten gerade die USA haben sich da
stark also klar positioniert und sagen
auch wir wollen eigentlich keine Systeme
liefern mit denen die Ukraine in
Russland angreifen kann man sollte dazu
sagen die Ukraine hat schon Systeme mit
denen sie in Russland angreifen kann
einfach gemeinsame eine gemeinsame
Grenze insofern das muss doch gar nicht
so weit sein aber genau also das ist
sicherlich eine Sorge des Westens und
das das verleitet mich auch wiederum
dazu zu sagen
denken nicht dass es jetzt einen
fundamentalen Wandel in der ukrainischen
Militär Taktik gibt und dass sie jetzt
regelmäßig Angriffe in in Russland
liegen werden oder anderweitig denn ja
sie haben genug damit zu tun
die eigene Territorium wieder zu erobern
und da dagegen Offensive zu machen und
es könnte ja eben Probleme mit den
westlichen Unterstützern geben und das
erscheint das ist scheint es mir nicht
der zu sein von dem militärischen und
und auch politischen Standpunkt
ausgesehen ähnlich äußert sich auch
jemand bei uns im Stream er oder sie
schreibt ist es nicht riskant käme der
Angriff direkt aus der Ukraine man hatte
ja gegenüber dem Westen versprochen
Russland nicht aktiv anzugreifen das
würde eine Eskalation darstellen würden
sie das unterschreiben
ich weiß nicht ob ich es jetzt nennen ob
ich eine Eskalation nennen würde wenn
die Eskalationen immer auf der
russischen Seite aber absolut also es
ist ja bekannt dass die meisten
westlichen Unterstützer nicht wollen
dass das der Krieg ihn nach Russland
hineingetragen wird irgendwie weiter ist
jetzt feste Abmachung gibt da bin ich
jetzt etwas überfragt das kann sich auch
ändern aber ja also ich glaube schon
dass mindestens nur offiziellen
Gesprächen da auch schon immer wieder
gesagt wird bitte nicht in Russland
hineintragen und vor dem Hintergrund
denke ich eben auch in der Tat das
müsste doch die Ukraine sich wirklich
sehr sehr gut überlegen ob das die
richtige der richtige Schritt zu
aktuellen Zeit ist und mir erscheint es
ihr gesagt als als fundamentale
Neuausrichtung nicht der richtige
Schritt jetzt so ein Anführungsstrichen
kleiner kleiner Angriff das kann schon
sein und ich denke jetzt nicht dass der
besten sich deswegen also auch wenn
jetzt nachgewiesen würde dass das direkt
aus der Ukraine kam und durch das mit
ukrainische Militär irgendwie
durchgeführt oder abgesegnet dass ich
der besten da jetzt irgendwie abwendet
dass das erscheint mir nicht plausibel
aber genau das könnte zu Problemen
führen politischen Probleme in der
Situation wo man die Unterstützung des
Westens ja weiterhin braucht daher
sagt vielleicht vielleicht eher im Jahr
nicht eine direkte
in ein direkter Schritt jetzt jetzt aus
der Ukraine vom ukrainischen Militär
zählen diese Drohnen denn die da
eingesetzt worden sind sie haben ja
vermutet welche das sein könnten würden
die überhaupt zu westlichen Waffen
zählen weil das was versprochen wurde
war ja dann keine westlichen Waffen
einzusetzen genau das ist ein sehr
wichtiger Punkt den sie ansprechen also
wie gesagt die Spekulation was für
Systeme das waren zeigen deuten auf
ukrainische Systeme hin also die in der
Ukraine gebaut werden die Ukraine hat
sich in den letzten also in der letzten
15 Monaten aber auch schon etwas davor
in den letzten ein zwei Jahren
klar auch entwickelt zu einem ja wegen
Drohnen Hersteller also die haben ganz
viele verschiedene brunnenhersteller die
da ja jetzt leider körperproble Systeme
eben auch auch bauen die eben dann im
Einsatz sind und
insofern braucht die Ukraine jetzt
spezifisch für Angriffe in Russland gar
nicht unbedingt westliche Waffensysteme
an also dass das wäre dann natürlich
noch so ein sagt man so ein lupol also
so ein so eine Entschuldigung oder so
eine so eine Art und Weise quasi einen
die auch immer geartetes
Abkommen mit dem besten nicht zu brechen
und eben nur eigene Systeme nehmen und
um Russland anzugreifen aber da bewegt
man sich natürlich auf dem schmalen Grad
weil Unterstützer wollen natürlich
generell nicht dass das der Krieg nach
Russland reingetragen wird und dann zu
sagen machen wir nicht nur mit unseren
eigenen Waffen das ist natürlich nur bis
zum gewissen gerade irgendwie wirklich
eine Lösung aber absolut also was wir
bisher wissen von Angriffen Russland
Angriffen der Ukraine innerhalb
Russlands die wurden soweit wir das
sehen können mit ukrainischen oder sogar
mit alten Subjekt Waffen durchführt und
eben nicht mit mit westlichen Waffen wir
hatten es in dieser Sendung schon kurz
angesprochen Anfang Mai gab es einen
Drohnenangriff im auf den Kreml also in
Russland was können Sie uns darüber
sagen zu vielleicht den Unterschieden
ist das ein ganz ähnlicher Angriff
jemand vergleichen kann oder war das
eine ganz andere Geschichte ähm also
diese Situation war insofern ähnliches
dass es eben ja ein Drohnenangriff war
auch auf den Kreml da ist ja eine eine
Drohne quasi am Dach des Krems
explodiert
die Unterschiede also zum ersten von dem
was wir sehen konnten von den Videos und
auch hier wie gesagt die Datenlage ist
nicht so groß nicht so nicht so gut
wirkt es so als sei das eine kleinere
Drohne gewesen mit auch weniger
Sprengkraft wahrscheinlich als die
Systeme die jetzt eingesetzt wurden was
mich damals zu dem Schluss gebracht hat
dass die wahrscheinlich eher nicht aus
der Ukraine kam also jetzt wirklich von
ukrainischen Territorium sondern eher in
der Nähe Moskau oder das gestartet wurde
auch das Spekulation aber das erscheint
mir plausibler insofern da
unwahrscheinlicher dass es direkt zum
ukrainischen her kam
bei den jetzigen Angriffen zumindest
plausibler dass es auch aus der Ukraine
hätten kommen können es waren auch viel
mehr Drohnen der entscheidende
Unterschied ist allerdings auch dass
diese Systeme dass diese Drohnen wohl
zum Teil größtenteils ich kann es schwer
sagen von der Moskauer Flugabwehr ja
entdeckt und abgefangen wurden also auch
so diese Einschlags
Löcher quasi an den Häusern die wir
gesehen haben da bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob das quasi erfolgreiche
Angriffe waren oder nicht eher zu Boden
stürzende Brunnen drohnenteile die
abgeschossen wurden denn die die Bilder
wir haben jetzt noch mal ein Bild das
sieht ja jetzt nicht aus als als seiner
groß was explodiert sondern eben mehr
was er an die Hauswand geflogen also da
hat wohl die Moskauer Flugabwehr war
durchaus in der Lage darauf auch zu
reagieren ist es trotzdem relativ
peinlich dass eben ohne bis dahin
gekommen ist
dahin gekommen sind aber immerhin hat
man sie wohl ja vielleicht beides geht
abgefahren es gab ja auch keine tote
also das so ein bisschen die
Unterschiede es kann sein dass dieselben
dass diese Angriffe von denselben
Akteuren geflogen wurden das ist absolut
möglich aber aber schon relevante
Unterschiede zwischen den beiden
vorkommen ist es gibt eine Frage zur
russischen Flugabwehr und zwar haben die
Russen nicht auch sogenannte Gemma die
die Drohnen fluguntauglich machen
ja absolut also es gibt verschiedene
Arten und Weisen Drohnen abzuwehren
elektronische Maßnahmen das sind diese
sogenannten Jammer und andere Systeme
diese Art und dann kinetische also
irgendeine Art und Weise wurden
abzuschießen äh das russische Militär
hat jetzt auch verlautbaren lassen dass
sie wohl diese Drohnen ähm sowohl mit
elektronischen Maßnahmen als auch eben
mit kinetischen bekämpft haben also ja
die Antwort ist absolut ja elektronische
Abwehr von Drohnen ist absolut Gang gebe
und kam hier wohl auch zum Einsatz
kann ich natürlich nicht überprüfen
macht aber Sinn als dass das ja auch in
der Ukraine stark eingesetzt wird auch
von beiden Seiten aber auch die
ukrainischen wohnen im ukrainischen
Gebiet haben teilweise Probleme eben mit
der russischen Flugabwehr in Form von
elektronischer Abwehr und kinetischer
also das ist eben im Einsatz zum Schluss
natürlich die Frage klar wie geht's
weiter die Userin Annie Mac möchte
wissen welche weiteren Reaktionen
erwartet die Expertin also sie Frau
Franke was erwarten sie aus Russland
welche Reaktion in dem Fall vielleicht
auch dann rückvergeltung muss man jetzt
erwarten
genau also
weitere sogenannte Vergeltung oder
irgendwie sie sagen
rückvergeltungsmaßnahmen sind absolut
möglich da muss ich allerdings wirklich
dazu sagen die diese diesen Vorwand
braucht Russland ja nicht also Russland
gerade ja seit 15 Monaten an insofern ja
es wird befürchte ich sehr auch morgen
und übermorgen weiterhin hier von
anderen ukrainische Städte bombardiert
das kann man dann aus dem Kreml
verkaufen als als gegen als als
Vergeltung aber ich habe überhaupt keine
Illusionen dass wenn es diesen Angriff
jetzt nicht gegeben hätten das ist nicht
genau dieselben Angriffe gegeben hätten
also dass das wird rhetorisch sicherlich
dann so verkauft aus dem Camel aber in
der Praxis glaube ich jetzt eigentlich
nicht dass da weiter eskaliert wird weiß
es nicht man auch nicht
schauen aber da erwarte ich jetzt
eigentlich weniger ich kann mir
vorstellen dass die westlichen Partner
noch mal der Ukraine auch sagen werden
also Angriffe innerhalb von Russland
sehen wir kritisch mit hässlichen
Systemen sowieso was ja jetzt nicht aber
das eben vor allen Dingen aber auch
sonst noch mal
kompliziert wird ja und ansonsten worauf
ich ehrlich gesagt schaue ist ist die
Frage wird das jetzt häufiger vorkommen
also da werden wir häufiger sollte
Angriffe kriegen weil dann wird es eben
interessant dann wird es eine Rolle
spielen ob Russland genug Flugabwehr im
eigenen Land hat um regelmäßige Angriffe
diese Art Abzug zu ihren und wenn nein
ja was machen sie dann müssen sie aus
der Ukraine abziehen
bleibt es bleibt es jetzt bei diesem
Angriff oder oder kommen da mehr und
wenn mehr kommen auch wieder die Frage
von wem kommt es dann ist dann das
englische Medizin ja oder haben wir am
Ende doch
relevante pro russische Kräfte irgendwie
ukrainische Kräfte irgendwo in Russland
brasiert das wäre ja auch eine
interessante also da halte ich einen
Auge drauf aber jetzt so ganz
grundsätzlich als Reaktion hier auf
erwarte ich jetzt von der Rhetorik
abgesehen eigentlich eine große weitere
Eskalation wie gesagt also Russland um
um mehr anzugreifen brauchen sie ja
offensichtlich kein Vorwand das haben
wir ja die letzten 15 Monate gesehen das
sagt die Sicherheit per Expertin Ulrike
Franke vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren heute abend danke für Ihre
Einschätzung sehr gerne und ihr im Chat
sagt ein Kommentar möchte ich noch
Vorlesen von Hip Hop Guru er oder sie
schreibt aber wir sollten nicht
vergessen dass es nicht darum geht
Russland anzugreifen sondern auch darum
die Rosen aus der Ukraine zu bekommen
und auch darüber natürlich mit noch mehr
Fokus auf die Ukraine was da gerade
passiert zum aktuellen Kriegsverlauf
werden wir wieder berichten bis dahin
seid ihr aktuell informiert bei ZDF
heute und für heute sage ich tschüss hab
einen schönen Abend ciao